hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to another edition of
my mom plays five nights at Freddy's
this time I'm playing five nights at
Freddy's 2 do you know about this game
it's a sequel to five nights at Freddy's
1 the one you play it last year yeah
you're scary a little bit not too bad I
have to go through that no no no no no
you have to go through different torture
see this one's less scary than the other
yeah it's more technically challenging
but I think with your experience in the
last one you're gonna be able to get
into this one just fine yeah okay
alright so put on the headphones it's
like a hair bit looks good looks good on
me yeah looks good okay so get into
position grab the mouse ya know go to
custom night this is another life right
so in this one you remember do you
remember these people Freddy I'm with
Freddy Bonnie chica foxy
yeah you remember him okay yeah yeah now
that was the first game that was is them
there's six more people in this one okay
okay alright so a mum it's a BB pony
Freddy
Toni Freddy Toni Bonnie Toni body Toni
tika Toni chica mango mango golden
Freddy yeah okay so bony the Toni the
Toni the Toni ones those are the ones
you got to watch out for so I'm gonna
make this a little easier for you I'm
gonna set you off cuz if it was on 2020s
the highest it'll go that's the most
difficult but I want you to have a nice
easy go of it called the cupcake
challenge Oh every everyone's on board
but everyone's in an easy level in a
five when you're ready go for it
okay ready ready whatever okay so in
this one it's a little bit differently
you remember how you have like the the
iPad that you got a slam up to your face
and then you Boop around on the cameras
do you remember
yes okay you still have that that's the
white bar there so hover over that and
click okay wait wait go up and then go
down there you go okay now see you got
all these cameras so if you look around
Oh camera 11 go there click on that oh
it too late I kind of forgot to tell you
about that that's a very important that
was a the puppet okay so all right so
need your coffee to be able to do this
go back flip the filter thing okay now
go to camera 11 Kevin your lever okay no
click and hold that okay hold it hold it
hold it why need help music box yes I'm
holding I'm holding what I'm gonna
happen let's put happen good you're good
that means it's good now if you let go
let go see how it flicks down yeah you
always gotta come back to that music box
and try it oh very quick now what do I
need to do so wide it back up again oh
okay okay okay okay
once that's down you can throw it up
throw the throw the screen down Wiggly
mm-hmm the screen down quickly how there
okay I forgot wait it's not put it back
up is it put it back up I can't remember
is that the is that the okay it's
unintentionally no no no I'm not doing
that why you keep asking me to play this
scary game on
last year last day because sometimes
families need regularity and and and
special occasions and there's a word for
that but I can't remember right now it's
the word for when families do stuff
together all the time and they call it a
yearly thing and they have like
commemorative moments where they have
this thing where you know they do things
every year what's the word for it
there's a word for it when they have
like annual tradition yeah come on Oh
click on here come on all right cool now
what I do
okay now you look around now you see
that's your helmet if there's a monster
in your Avenue click on that okay now
click back now okay go to camera 1111
click click hurt see when you open up
spearmint it'll open on the last thing
you opened right mm-hmm so you don't
need to click camera 11 again so click
on old and put it down all right
what
eleven I know that I'm gonna I'm gonna
wind this up by pushing this one down
another mechanic okay I'll put that up
okay control turns on a light down your
hallway you want to check the hallway Oh
something in there I saw I so Freddie Oh
Freddie oh oh this is much harder than
the last one I'm gonna come clean I've
been you've technically been on what's
called custom night which is a lot
harder
I'm gonna go easy on all you have to do
is hit new game okay then we're gonna
start from the I just was just for a
laugh I didn't know that I was that bad
okay I can see better camera a has a
dead body here Tuoba
yeah dead right
I see chica Bonnie what is this
Freddy dad okay should I go chemistry
camera 1 by 6
oh gods warrants warning your flashlight
hasn't bad oh sure I need like alright
this is that this is Freddy right there
yeah so what should I do
just come on get out of here I'm the
lookout okay come on come on oh come on
wind up muse your way oh come on
come on what's gonna happen how can I
get away with this you can always go
away to other places but you just have
to come back for the regular interval
why because if you don't you'll die oh
if I don't check on them know me yeah
they'll sneak on you okay so I have to
sneak on them right yeah oh I got it I
got it the counters so muck come on come
on I'll let you in on a secret if you go
to camera nine okay how people are
missing right yeah good question
Tobin let me see yeah yeah I got you hey
I don't wish you better okay why should
I just make sure they don't get oh yeah
oh why not pumping okay now what stuck
on it where's Barney Barney was nine
wasn't it nine or good boy Bonni Bonni
right yeah no no yeah that's Barney okay
boyo and yeah there's Bonnie okay that's
ready Freddy I don't know Freddy's the
blue one right I don't know where's
Freddy seven it's a chick eyes seven
Darius
gah I gotcha gotcha gotcha
mommy is so fast oh yeah mommy is good
oh thank you
is that for me thank you chica is asleep
gotta check on later see you later I
think is trying to get close five five
five
okay it's ready I gotcha wait okay all
right so cute
okay put the camera down mm big warning
okay I don't know okay
now she's gonna come out later that vent
okay just oh I can your music box
oh yeah wine a wine okay now go back
when you go back to look at that vent
hey you know nothing yet look over there
no she's scared Obama mommy player is so
scary
no you don't want to mess with me no but
well what about you know Freddy was
Freddy was on the move you know you may
want to look out on the five
oh where you hid your flashlight Oh Oh
to the right oh no wait okay
stay don't move solve Oh Boone even
boutique now your music box
oh okay okay
wait no take it that's a miracle
listen he was kind of cute
yeah that was kind of cute nein um
you're still there good boy good boy I
always tell my dog goodbye
keep that music box wound up good girl
I can't ever want to get behind on that
you can stay on top of it yeah I think
I'm gonna make it yeah you can do this
I'm watching you I'm watching oh it's
cause I'm in trouble if they go maybe
they want to catch me yeah you think
that maybe they went to Cameron I don't
think we can turn on your flashlight on
Tambor one did you see me Oh Shh all
right bunny now your music box what
should I do
music boss oh okay I'm minding the music
come on 3:00 a.m. come on come on where
was it 9:00 no no wait we can where's
chica oh not a four oh she's gone seven
yeah yeah where's Barney Barney - no oh
nine three eight oh man I'm in trouble
oh I'm in deep
you need the lights
there's good effort
there's a good effort just disappointing
I don't like to party okay okay all
right see who's gonna win here I'm not
gonna let you win 3:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m.
okay I need to find you guys okay
stay there check okay okay still not
there I need to wind up yeah yeah good
job good job good job good job
oh hey dear
where's you gotta find Freddy Freddy
okay
oh my god end up nine oh oh oh oh my god
oh god no don't don't disappoint me
mommy's too last week wait go back to
three oh yeah there okay getting close
getting close
you're fine turn off the light no you
just gotta make sure they don't get two
cameras one and camera two is if they
get to camera one camera two that means
they're close
you also have to check down the main
hallway so put the carabao actually wind
up the music box first then once that's
wind-up
okay right okay back up
okay a little bit okay one one is anyone
there
ah - chronic okay keep an eye on that
one okay all right no way a good wine up
your music box okay
5 o clock 5 a.m. come on all right check
do again
my life was depend on you guys oh come
on put it down put the shot put the
light off there he's coming don't worry
about that it's fine he's not that close
yet but you gotta keep an eye on him
so stay here until you have to wind up
the music box
okay stay 5 a.m. now go wide up the
music bus ride it up wide now put it
when you put it back down there turn the
flashlight right on look down the hall
all right now check the light on the
right
check all right off keep an eye on that
guy come on come on let me win oh all
right you're gonna have to check the
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a miracle okay okay so it's so
exciting all right you did it hey
anybody want to lose weight that's the
way up too lazy because it's gonna pump
your heart rate so fast
you don't have to go run just play this
one a few few minutes you're gonna lose
a lot of calories
yeah makes sense makes it all right you
ready to play the next game no do I have
to yeah that's too hard this is much fun
easy for me there's another game though
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you mom for joining me on
this one and as always we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]